je suis fatous y est je suis dramaturge
généralement les gens écarquillent les
yeux lorsque je dis ça souvent je dis
que je suis auteur dramatique et là j'ai
droit en france mansour sy
d'interrogateurs on ne comprend pas trop
de quoi je parle est la plupart du temps
je suis plus simple je dis que je suis
écrivain et que je crie du théâtre et la
question automatique que l'on me pose et
que peut être vous même vous m'auriez
posé c'est tu arrives à gagner ta vie
avec ça ou qu'est ce que tu fais à côté
ma réponse est automatique
je dis que oui j'arrive à gagner ma vie
mais j'enfonce un tout petit peu plus le
clou je dis que je suis juriste aussi et
là je vois le soulagement sur le visage
et mon interlocuteur il se dit à au
moins le travail
le théâtre c'est juste un passe temps je
lave ou lorsque j'étais étudiante en
droit à strasbourg et que je discutais
avec mes amis je rêvais du statut de la
cad supérieur le virement du salaire qui
fait exploser le compte en banque
le tailleur noir de la femme
indépendante et fière de l'être
quand je suis venu à abidjan la réalité
à un thème tout public différentes
j'ai déprimé longtemps de ne pas voir
une statue mais finalement je me dis que
rien ne me dit que j'aurais été heureux
en fait
et ceci m'amène à vous poser la question
de savoir si vous êtes vraiment content
de ce que vous faites au quotidien dans
tout travail il ya des hauts et des bas
mais est ce que vous êtes réellement
satisfaits de la voie que vous avez
choisi ainsi huit ans mieux sinon c'est
vrai que la plupart du temps les gens
travaillent par défaut oui ils ne se
rendent pas compte en fait et c'est le
plus grave qu'il réalise en fait les
aspirations d'autres personnes
ils font ce qu'on attend d'eux tout
simplement pourquoi choisir la
difficulté qu'on peut avoir la facilité
n'est ce pas c'est aussi ce que je pense
sauf que moi la facilité n'a pas voulu
de moi je crois même qu'elle me fuit
mais ce qui est paradoxal avec ma
difficulté c'est qu'à défaut de m'avoir
donné le statut de la femme classique
dont je rêvais j'ai aujourd'hui celui de
la femme exceptionnelle qui écrit du
théâtre et qui a libéré des stéréotypes
de la société j'essaie franchement qu'il
lit du théâtre am à merci à quand
remonte votre dernier pièces de théâtre
lui le spectacle encore les gens vont
voir des spectacles de théâtre mais la
littérature dramatique ne figure pas au
top
mon deuxième challenge je suis une femme
vous connaissez combien de femmes
africaines qui écrivent du théâtre et
qui sont baissées loup mondialement
reconnue sur le jeu des questions
réponses
une femme écrivain théâtre merci merci
linking peut-être c'est une pionnière
mais après en fait généralement c'est le
silence quand je pose cette question
nous somme inconnue
nous sommes anonymes
nous sommes des femmes africaines
la société considère que notre rôle ce
n'est pas de courir le monde peut
exercer un hack personne ne considère
nous sommes des femmes africaines
la société considère que notre rôle
c'est d'être des mais aimante des
épouses présentes
nous pouvons même exercé tous les
métiers que nous voulons sauf du théâtre
du théâtre soyons sérieux le théâtre ça
ne paye pas les factures
je pense pour ma part que payer les
factures ça soulage ça ne rend pas
heureux mais nous vivons dans un système
où payer les factures est une réalité
soyons concrets c'est très philosophique
ce que je viens de dire
il faut bien payer ses factures et c'est
ce qui justifie que la plupart du temps
ces femmes africaines abandonnent leurs
rêves avant même d'avoir commencé
mais comme il faut du tout pour faire un
monde et à une catégorie de femmes
africaines obstiné et têtu dont je fait
heureusement parti qui a décidé de
continuer l'aventuré
une catégorie de femmes africaines
obstiné et têtu pour qu'ils se lever
tous les matins pour réaliser leur
objectif n'est pas une conversion
montables quand j'y pense je me dis que
je suis une magicienne des mots imaginez
un peu avec une pièce de théâtre des
mots sur un papier je donne du travail à
des comédiens à des metteurs en scène à
des techniciens du spectacle vivant des
personnes qui ont décidé de vivre
véritablement de leur passion
heureusement partout dans le monde avec
une pièce de théâtre des mots sur un
papier je voyage comme n'importe quel
directeur général je fais des rencontres
inimaginable je vis les plus belles
expériences c'est même grâce au théâtre
que je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
il y a une différence fondamentale et
c'est un ami qui me l'a appris
entre réussir dans la vie et réussir sa
vie
il y a aussi cette phrase que vous voyez
l'un qui fonctionne comme un véritable
catalyseur pour moi que j'ai entendu
dans un film one love
nous avons toujours le choix entre deux
chemins un large et 1 escarpée mais le
plus difficile mènent souvent au bonheur
alors s'il ya quelque chose que je
pourrais éventuellement vous dire qui
pourrait vous influencer c'est de ne pas
avoir peur de la difficulté c'est très
facile à dire mais huit n'ayez pas peur
de la difficulté et ne veut surtout pas
peur du regard des autres
je pense que leur regard est souvent
le complexe qui manifestent vis-à-vis de
vous réinventez vos coudes
c'est le thème libérer votre esprit mais
surtout soyez vous et non ce que les
autres veulent que vous soyez je vous
souhaite de réussir votre vie et que
vous donner les moyens de le faire pour
ma part vous avez en face de vous une
femme qui pense qu'elle réussit sa vie
en écrivant des pièces de théâtre pour
un public et je vais vous montrer
comment je fais je vais vous inviter
dans mon univers est la première règle
dans mon univers c'est qu'on est libre
donc je vais m'asseoir à votre niveau et
je vais sortie du circle normalement
c'est possible vous pouvez attacher vos
ceintures et priez aussi jamais les
bouleversements les voyages dans mon
univers souvent tu le mets dieu je vais
vous inviter à visualiser une ceni avec
moi pas tout à fait terminé mais
certains de mes personnages avaient
envie de s'exprimer avec vous et donc je
vous invite à à suivre un tout petit peu
le trajet
soyez relax et détendue vous avez prié
un homme est assis dans le bus à côté de
lui toute une population d'hommes et de
femmes assis ou debout
il est 19 heures heure de pointe un
lundi l'homme ne parle à personne
personne ne parle à personne à côté de
lui à 19 heures de pointe lundi
personne n'a envie de parler à personne
l'homme regarde à travers la vitre du
bus son regard croise celui d'une femme
normalement à 19 heures de pointe lundi
plus personne ne regarde plus personne
mais il voit bien les yeux d'une femme
orienté vers lui à 6 quelque part il
voit son regard se réfléter en face de
lui
elle le regarde c'est certain il la
regarde c'est inévitable ils se
regardent à travers la transparence de
la vitre du bus il est toujours 19
heures heure de pointe à lundi l'homme
regarde la femme la femme regard de
l'homme le jeu se disent et si on se
souriaient
il la regarde elle le regarde mais leur
souris restent figés dans leur
conscience
il la regarde elle le regarde impossible
de tirer les lèvres il la regarde elle
le regarde la vitrine du bus est une
barrière qu'ils ne peuvent pas
transpercé par un sourire
il la regarde elle le regarde ça ne se
fait pas de sourire aux inconnus surtout
à travers le reflet d'une vitre il la
regarde elle le regarde les yeux
immobilisé les lèvres crispé par une
force qui les dépasse il n'est peut-être
plus 19 heures de pointe lundi
l'homme ne regarde plus sa montre mais
ils sont toujours qu'une population
d'hommes et de femmes montent et
descendent du bus le soleil en potes ses
rayons loin de l'inter le bus continue
sa traversée
mais l'homme continue de regarder la
femme la femme continue de regarder
elle a le regard fier pense l'homme il a
le regard triste de penser la femme
et si je lui souris et pense utile j'ai
honte j'ai pu les coeurs battent la
chamade
mais pourquoi tant d'hésitations pour un
sourire un sourire c'est universel il
n'a pas de couleur de pays pas de
nationalité pas de sexe pas de genre pas
de statut social pas de prix un sourire
c'est l'ouverture du coeur un sourire
c'est humain un sourire ses éternels le
temps a cessé de jouer sa partition
depuis que l'homme sourit à la femme
depuis que la femme sourit à l'homme ils
se sourient et ne peuvent plus entendre
l'explosion détonations déflagration d
intégration ils se sourient et ne
peuvent plus entendre lawrence du peuple
frayeur ils se sourient ils ne peuvent
plus entendre l'appel de la mort en une
minute toutes les vies du bus vole en
éclats mais leur sourire est intacte
en une minute tout n'est plus que chaos
est leur souffle est faux tout n'est
plus que deuil souffrent ces révoltes
mais leurs sourires domine le monde
c'était un lundi dans un bus à peut-être
une heure de pointe un homme souviennent
à une femme une femme soutien à un homme
un nombre avait les murs de la société
une femme bravait les murs du coeur un
homme et une femme disait adieu à ce
monde
le sourire plus puissant que jamais
merci